how to find your superpower
I made a video not too long ago about
finding your superpower and why it's
important
the idea behind finding your superpower
is find the one thing that you're really
great at that you're better than anybody
else in the world that you can just pour
everything into and focus on that
because when you can focus on what
you're best at your chance of success in
business and your happiness level to
just go up dramatically the more you
force yourself to do things that you're
not good at because you feel you should
do it or society tells you that you
should do it then you're not going to be
successful and from that video I got a
comment from one of my viewers chef
Stevie the chef's has been a loyal
viewer and it's been waiting for this
video so chefs you're calling me out man
here's the video hopefully you get some
value from it so here's a question from
chefs I'm currently trying to learn how
to code websites to become the next best
thing that's happened to the Internet
I'm struggling to retain some
information I learned after watching
this video it made me think is this
really for me my point is what do I do
if I haven't found my superpower yet in
the field that I want to be in so here's
the thing okay if you're asking yourself
what was the question is this really for
me if you're doing something and you're
asking yourself this is really for me
it's probably not for you and I don't
know what your reason for getting into
this thing is but maybe there's another
way to tackle it look and explore and
try to find another way to go at it
without you forcing yourself the code
you forcing yourself the program when
you're not interested in programming
it's not going to work like the guys who
love programming let them focus on being
programmers you've got to do something
else whatever vision you have for the
world
you know what the change that you want
to make the product or service you want
to launch there are different ways to go
at it and the solution is not going to
be you becoming the programmer that's
kind of what you've locked in your head
now for this to work I have to be a
programmer
but for it to be successful you have to
not be the programmer because you're
forcing yourself to learn it and when
you force yourself to learn something
you're not going to have success you
have to explore explore different ways
explore other people you can work with
really figure out what you're good at
and what you like and how you can make
that into a business and maybe something
that that is totally unexpected like you
can't plan for this stuff here's an
example okay I'm an investor in a salsa
dancing company here in Toronto and it's
probably the largest salsa dancing
school in North America teach five six
thousand people a year how to dance
salsa I've started in this business as a
student I was just looking to have fun
and dance and I did I went in I loved it
it was just a hobby it was fun I became
excited about it I was passionate about
it I got more and more and more involved
as her DJ I started helping people learn
and teach and then became an investor in
the business and that that was a process
but I loved it
and I could get lost in it and that's
the sign because if I went in looking at
that business and said I'm going to be
an investor in this company or the
thought this is crazy what do I know
about salsa nothing what about the music
nothing I'm tall which means they'll
take bigger steps I didn't grow up with
it I don't know the music at all I don't
know the language still don't
it has everything stacked against me for
me being a success in that business but
the equalizer the thing that makes a
difference is the passion and the love I
love it and so it helped make it a huge
success you are not getting that in
programming right now you do not get
lost in the code you do not sit there
wake up at you know 6:00 in the morning
start coding and in 6:00 at night you
ready for dinner time and you don't even
know where the time line that's not you
right now you're forcing yourself to
learn you're forcing yourself to
memorize and you're wondering is this
for me it's not for you go find
something else explore you may find your
salsa for me you may sit maybe something
totally unrelated that still helps you
get to your goal but you won't know
until you try and don't be a
free to try something and quit you tried
programming it's not working have the
courage to quit and do something else
try something else and fail fast at that
and something else until you find
something that you can get lost in and
love and say this is chefs this is what
I'm all about
I'm going to own this when you do that
you'll find your moment and then the
internet will see something they've
never seen before
believe those are you watching you liked
the video give it a thumbs up subscribe
if you want to see more videos and let
me know you think leave a comment below
ask a question I'll make a video
response thank you guys so much I love
Wednesday is making these videos for you
I'll see you soon